organizers and attendees were at the
ponds for this conference they say there
has to be a new approach to student
safety it can no longer be about adding
more school resource officers security
cameras or even arming teachers the
student Safety and Security conference
brought 300 School professionals from
all 50 states Christopher claw was one
of them he's a safety coordinator at a
Navajo Nation school district for our
district is
um the potential is there
the prevention is there now it's just
preparing our students and staff to
respond and react to the situation claw
says there aren't many resources
available on the reservation counselors
who help students plan for college may
also have to help kids with problems
they're facing at home so when kids come
to school you know they're they're safe
they feel safe they want to be safe
Lillet Campbell is a principal of a
small private school in Washington DC
while she has not dealt with a serious
incident yet she wants to be prepared
doesn't mean that something like a
school shooter or any of these other
things cannot come up like I said we've
been very very fortunate but I feel like
at some point your luck might run out so
we need to be prepared Dr Steven Soroka
an expert on school safety says he's
bringing a new approach to this issue
once you get to the heart you can get to
the head and that's what I think is
important saroka says you can no longer
prevent school shootings all all you can
do is reduce the risk of one you cannot
legislate this problem away you can't
put a bunch of officers in a school and
make it go away we have to have a bigger
a comprehensive approach to it experts
say more than 90 percent of School
shooters told a family member or friend
of their attentions a stat they say
emphasizes why it's important that we
take these issues seriously according to
their pogs Joshua peguero eight news now